>> Tucker: THIS WEEK, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOME IS
EXPECTED TO ASK FOR $1.4 BILLION
TO FIGHT HOMELESSNESS.
IT WOULD DO NOTHING TO REDUCE
THE INCIDENCE OF HOMELESSNESS.
NOTHING THEY'VE TRIED IN THAT
STATE HAS.
THEY'RE UNWILLING TO FIX THE
CORE PROBLEM.
IN SAN FRANCISCO, POLICE IN
ACTION AGAINST CRIME AND
VAGRANCY HAS BECOME SO BAD THAT
LOCALS ARE TURNING TO PRIVATE
POLICE.
>> YEAH, HI, CAN I HELP YOU?
>> MEET TOBY CLEMMONS.
HE ISN'T AN ORDINARY COP.
IN FACT, HE'S NOT A COP AT ALL.
>> WE ARE PAID FOR BY PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND MERCHANTS.
>> WE SPENT TWO HOURS RIDING
ALONG WITH CLEMMONS AS HE
FIELDED CALL AFTER CALL, MOSTLY
ABOUT DRUG ADDICTS LINING THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SIDEWALKS.
>> I TALKED HIM AND ENCOURAGED
HIM TO MOVE.
>> OUTSIDE THE LIBRARY WHICH
THEY USE AS A DAY SHELTER, HE
WAS ACCOSTED BY THIS MAN.
>> PROTESTING HERE IF I WANTED
TO, RIGHT?
>> DO YOU THINK --
[ INAUDIBLE ]
>> Tucker: THE CASTRO DISTRICT
IS RICH.
>> THE RESIDENTS THAT LIVE ON
THESE STREETS, THEY PAY FOR OUR
SERVICE.
>> THE AREA'S RICHEST RESIDENTS
VOTED TO CREATE A BENEFIT
DISTRICT, THAT'S BUREAUCRATIC
JARGON FOR A PRIVATE GOVERNMENT.
>> SOME OF THE MOST COMMON CALLS
I GET FROM RESIDENTS, SOMEBODY'S
SETTING UP A TENT IN FRONT OF
OUR HOUSE.
>> Tucker: THE BENEFIT DISTRICT
PAYS PEOPLE TO PATROL THE
STREETS, PICK UP TRASH, AND
REMOVE GRAFFITI.
>> MOST CITIES THEY WOULD.
>> Tucker: NOT SAN FRANCISCO,
WHERE PROPERTY OWNERS ARE FORCED
TO PAY MANDATORY FEES TO FINANCE
SERVICES THE CITY FAILS TO
PROVIDE.
>> IT'S THE WORST I'VE EVERY
SEEN.
>> Tucker: JOHN RUNS A HOTEL
NEAR UNION SQUARE.
HIS NEIGHBORHOOD HAS GOTTEN SO
BAD THAT HE REPEATEDLY DEALS
WITH HORRIFIED HOTEL GUESTS.
>> THEY ARE TROUBLED BY THE
CLEANLINESS.
THE FACT THAT THEY AT TIMES
DON'T FEEL SAFE.
SEEING PEOPLE WHO ARE SLEEPING
ON THE SIDEWALKS.
THEY'RE BAFFLED.
>> Tucker: NOT ALL IN SAN
FRANCISCO ARE PRIVILEGED ENOUGH
TO AFFORD PRIVATE POLICING.
SINCE THE CITY'S PROSECUTORS ARE
UNWILLING TO ENFORCE THE LAW,
THERE'S NOT MUCH PATROL
SPECIALISTS CAN DO.
>> THEY GO TO THE NEXT CORNER,
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO MOVE THEM
AGAIN.
>> IT DOES GET FRUSTRATING.
YOU OFFER THEM SERVICES, THEY
DON'T WANT SERVICES.
A LOT OF THEM CHOOSE TO BE ON
THE STREET BECAUSE IT'S A LIFE
STYLE THEY LIKE.
>> Tucker: THIS SERIES CONTINUES
THIS ENTIRE WEEK WITH THINGS AS
BAD AS THEY ARE THERE.
YOU MIGHT THINK HOUSING IN SAN
FRANCISCO MIGHT GET A LITTLE
CHEAPER, BUT SOMEHOW IT'S GOTTEN
MORE EXPENSIVE.
ORDINARY PEOPLE WITH JOBS ARE
TRYING DESPERATE MEASURES.